la primera reacción temprano el líder de
los socialdemócratas olaf scholz se
dirigió a los alemanes y presentó su
propuesta de hacer una alianza con los
verdes y los liberales como decían
ustedes pero yo me pregunto con quién
más podría hacerla para conseguir un 50
por ciento de los votos y poder tener no
cierto la cancillería por su parte
estamos esperando una comparecencia del
líder de la cdu que sigue empeñado por
ahora en formar coalición con lo mismo
con los verdes y con los liberales
entonces la pelota ahora está del lado
de esos dos partidos pero hay que decir
que hoy un líder de la cdu pidió al ayer
que termine con este empeño de
convertirse en canciller de hecho el
partido perdió varias circunscripciones
entre ellas donde era diputada ángela
merkel es la peor derrota como ustedes
decían del partido hace un rato también
habló el líder de los liberales he dicho
que se ha acercado ya a los ecologistas
lo hizo anoche y piensa en estos
partidos que son en realidad los grandes
ganadores de estas elecciones que les
toca a ellos quizás elegir cuál es el
partido con el que van a hacer coalición
y no al revés porque son ellos los
grandes vencedores de la jornada y es
raúl ahora a erika con estos resultados
ajustados por cada partido ha anunciado
su voluntad de formar gobierno como ya
lo estábamos hablando con la sed y con
el
nombre por ahora pero no queda con olas
ahora perdón y no queda claro en todas
las quién podría ser el próximo
canciller qué va a pasar con esto
claro no queda claro porque ha pasado ya
la historia de alemania raúl tres veces
que el partido más votado no
necesariamente ha sido el que terminado
imponiendo su canciller lo que es cierto
recordemos también es que no va haber
coalición roji en rojo negra es decir
con los socialdemócratas y la democracia
cristiana que es la que ha gobernado
este país durante tres de los cuatro
gobiernos de angela merkel bueno ahora
bien en las negociaciones la última vez
fueron cinco meses este año los dos
partidos grandes se comprometieron a que
antes de navidad' angela merkel ya no
sea la canciller de este país pero en
realidad como decíamos no está todavía
en sus manos quizás más bien en estos
dos nuevos partidos jóvenes y ver hasta
dónde van a acceder cada uno en sus
propuestas porque hay temas ideológicos
que son irreconciliables entre los
ecologistas y los liberales que son
justamente más de economía liberal de
mercado capitalista y por otra parte los
verdes quieren aumentar impuestos
quieren aumentar salario mínimo reducir
o poner un límite a la velocidad las
carreteras en final son escuelas
distintas que no se sabe cómo se van a
conciliar y además los liberales han
dicho obviamente que tienen más afinidad
con la cdu
con los socialdemócratas así que va a
ser difícil va a ser difícil raúl no
podemos decir cuánto va a durar pero
ojalá se pongan de acuerdo antes de
navidad' por lo menos para que pueda
descansar aquí la merkel